everything in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has been slowly building up to
the arrival of Thanos and after years of
waiting Avengers infinity war is finally
here which raises just one big question
for superhero fans now what of course
Marvel has already allegedly created a
meticulous master plan that runs through
the Year 2028
but since they aren't telling anyone
what they have in mind we'll just have
to look the clues to figure out just how
infinity war will change the MCU forever
expect departures the contractual
obligations for many of the stars of the
MCU end with Avengers infinity war
rumors and reports have circulated for
years that some of the MC used biggest
stars would be unwilling to renew with
Robert Downey jr. Chris Evans and Chris
Hemsworth all stating at various times
that they were planning to leave the MCU
at the end of their contracts of course
people can change their minds and being
offered hundreds of millions of dollars
often helps but considering pretty much
every Marvel superhero was killed in the
Infinity Gauntlet comic book series that
infinity war is based on it would seem
like Marvel has been planning the
perfect send-off for the current version
of the MCU and the current lineup of
stars for years while most are signed
through the Infinity war follow-up in
2019 Avengers for chances are pretty
good that infinity war is at least the
beginning of the end for everything
you've known and loved about the MCU for
the past decade expect new arrivals if
the thought of losing your favorite
superheroes is a big old bummer
don't worry because Marvel has plenty of
other characters waiting in the wings
for their close up sure some of the
characters left and their stabl may not
be as famous as their current lineup but
be honest had you ever heard of the
guardians of the galaxy before they
became the coolest thing in any universe
what about Doctor Strange are ant-man or
even Iron Man yes
hard as it may be to remember now but
Iron Man was once considered a
second-string hero and featuring him in
his own solo film was regarded as a
massive risk when the first Iron Man
film came out a decade ago so don't
worry if you'd never heard of Moon
Knight brother voodoo or shang-chi
master of kungfu
because given marvel's track record
chances are they'll be your new
favourite character before the final
credits finish rolling expect more
diversity the undeniable critical and
commercial success of black panther
should be enough to convince even the
most doubtful cynic that after infinity
war we should expect to see Marvel
Studios doubling and tripling down on
its commitment to
versity starring mostly actors of color
written and directed by people of color
black panther proved if nothing else
there's no good reason to shy away from
Marvel's collection of more diverse
heroes with the success of black panther
the highly anticipated Captain Marvel
waiting in the wings Avengers infinity
Wars ensemble cast featuring numerous
people of color and women the persistent
whispers of a solo black widow movie and
a still largely untapped reserve of
Marvel Comics characters waiting for the
names to be called Marvel movie fans
should expect to not only see more women
heroes and heroes of color but their
real-life counterparts writing and
directing expect more laughs Marvel
movies are funny and they'll continue to
be funny though The Avengers franchise
which sits at the heart of the MCU has
been a deadly serious affair with deep
real-world themes and moral debates it's
also been laced with all sorts of funny
gags and light asides unlike the DC
extended universe films in the MCU are
actually fun to watch and its films like
guardians of the galaxy and thor
ragnarok have proven the more audiences
laugh the more money they're likely to
spend seeing it again
thor ragnarok was even so fun that stark
Chris Hemsworth reportedly has been
reconsidering his decision to leave the
MCU and all that added humour helped
thor ragnarok
earn not just the most money of the
three Thor films but also the best
reviews in fact one of the few
criticisms of the movie was that it
might have been too funny given the
success of Ragnarok and revitalizing one
of Marvel's key franchises though don't
expect the laughs to stop anytime soon
especially with ant-man of the wasp and
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 already in
the pipeline the events of infinity war
may be sad but chances are Marvel has a
plan to turn that frown upside down
sooner rather than later expect more
variety maybe the biggest secret of
Marvel's success is the fact that while
they seem to be making superhero movies
they're actually making movies from all
sorts of different genres that just
happened to feature superheroes as the
main characters think about it
Captain America Winter Soldier was a
classic 70 style espionage movie
guardians at the galaxy was a space
opera while Doctor Strange and Thor the
dark world were fantasy films ant-man
was a high school
well a man and the wasp has been
described as a rom-com in spider-man
homecoming was their take on the classic
John Hughes high school drama D it's
that non formula formula that has worked
so well for Marvel up until this point
so fans should expect to see more of the
same by expecting less of the same when
it comes to infinity war Marvel isn't
going to follow up their big smash them
up epic action crossover with more of
those instead they're likely to branch
out even further
picking characters that work well in
different types of films want to see a
Marvel Western they've got the two
gunkid for that a marvel horror movie
how about Simon Garth the zombie a
marvel war movie hello John Kowalski it
sounds weird but Marvel plays it safe by
not playing it safe so going forward
expect even more variety than we've
gotten so far
expect more space one of the corners of
the Marvel Universe that has found
nothing but success is the cosmos both
guardians of the galaxy films were hits
and liked humor
the cosmic element added to thor
ragnarok was a key ingredient to turning
around the franchise while the first
adventures brought us an alien invasion
Avengers infinity war promises an even
stronger attachment to Marvel's cosmic
mythology than ever with quasar nova
adam warlock moon dragon and more there
are almost as many heroes among the
stars as there are on Marvel's earth and
the possible acquisition of Fox's
properties opens even more doors the
Fantastic Four cosmic explorers and the
Silver Surfer is the ultimate cosmic
hero considering all the success Marvel
has had in space and the fact that its
audience is now familiar enough with its
cosmic mythology to not burden future
films with extraneous explanations
there's no reason to think Marvel won't
explore other far-out franchises expect
complete annihilation so what will
Marvel's next giant film crossover event
B once infinity war and Avengers 4 have
come and gone well if Marvel does use
infinity war and the acquisition of the
Fantastic Four in the Silver Surfer as
an excuse to launch even more cool
outerspace movies the next logical step
is complete annihilation that's because
in the comics while the earthbound
heroes were all busy fighting each other
with their civil war thing Marvel's
space heroes were engaged at a galaxy
spanning Armageddon called annihilation
with the guardians of the galaxy leading
the way
with infinity war bringing the alien
menace to earth the next logical step
for our heroes is to take that fight
back into space
of course Marvel has plenty of other
massive crossover storylines they could
do instead
but given the popularity of their sci-fi
franchises and the space connections
evident in 2019 s Captain Marvel which
seems set to include the space war
between the Kree and the Skrull
annihilation seems like the safest bet
expect the x-men finally the acquisition
of Fox would provide the MCU with the
most obvious new direction now that the
threat from without has been taken care
of what about the threat from within
posed by the emergence of a mutant
population hiding among us with the
Avengers potentially gone who could
possibly stand up to the danger of the
x-men it's inevitable that the x-men
will play a major role in the MCU once
Disney has the rights to the characters
we just don't know yet how it will play
out well Thanos use the reality warping
Infinity Gauntlet to somehow merge the
MCU with Fox's x-men universe or will
the characters develop organically with
the x-men franchise being rebooted
completely like spider-man was so that
the emergence of the mutant menace
becomes the cornerstone of Marvel's next
phase and beyond
however Marvel ends up bringing the
x-men into the MCU
once they are there there's no question
that they're going to be at the center
of everything that follows and not
necessarily as heroes that the MCU
follow the comics by having Cyclops
become the big bad guy and a race war
between humans and mutants in a world
without the Avengers as we know them
anything is possible thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]